I should we start with Poland what do we
need to do about what's going on well
it's obviously deeply deeply concerning
isn't it and Poland is a an ally of ours
our bonds of Friendship with Poland are
deep and strong
I don't want to speculate uh I'm not in
a position to speculate anyway but
obviously we need our NATO allies to
investigate what's happened get to the
bottom of what's happened but we do need
to be calm and let's not rush into
anything here
um and allow the International Community
to work out what's going on yeah
whatever
uh the findings of the investigation do
you agree with the Prime Minister that
this would not have happened if Russia
had not invaded Ukraine well that is of
course the backdrops of all of this and
our support and solidarity with Ukraine
remains steadfast and of course
absolutely we would not be in this
situation if it wasn't for this
absolutely appalling invasion of Ukraine
by Russia and again the you know the
whole of the International Community is
united in saying to Russia you should
not be doing this and you need to back
off and we'll continue to support
Ukraine in any way we can
um one of the byproducts of what's
happening in Ukraine is inflation Rising
right around the world not least because
of food costs grain from Ukraine prices
um going up 11.1 today yeah and
absolutely and actually 16 for food year
on year that's the highest level for
food since uh 1977 so well 45 years
um or so this is deeply deeply worrying
and of course we're less able to weather
these storms in the UK because we've had
12 12 years of lackluster economic
performance in the UK now what I would
say to the government is that you can
take measures to strengthen our economy
we shouldn't have had that disastrous
budget seven or eight weeks ago which
led to a run on Pension funds to
mortgage rates increasing for many
homeowners across the country but you
can do things by by getting people back
to work we've got over a million
vacancies in our economy yet we've got
one and a half million people unemployed
and people who are out of work because
of sickness is now over two and a half
million the highest on record I think we
should ape should be aiming for the
highest employment in the G7 and I want
to see and I would introduce if I was
the Secretary of State for working
pensions welfare reforms to support
people to move into good quality jobs
and stay in workers that's one of the
ways getting more people into the work
is one of the ways in which you can
tackle this inflation in our economy
that disastrous mini budget nothing to
do with this Chancellor though
um what does he need to do
um tomorrow to try to steady the ship
well it was a conservative party who
gave us
it wasn't him but it was the
conservative party who gave us this
disastrous budget which led to the run
on Pension funds and mortgage rates
going up look I think we need to give
our pensioners a fair increase in the
pension they shouldn't see the pension
cut I think working people these
disabled people deserve a fair increase
in their Universal credit payment that
shouldn't be cut in real terms however
we've been putting pressure on the
chancellor to honor his promises to the
poor risk and the vulnerable and
pensioners in society but as I say in
the minimum wage we expect let's see if
that is a if the minimum wage goes up
that is a good thing quite obviously but
I don't want to see uh people's
standards of living cut back because we
see further Cuts in things like the
Universal Credit or the pension and
we've got to do give people support to
get into work we should not be writing
off people to a life on benefits because
because they've not because they're sick
and unwell but not getting any help from
the system that's one of the reforms I'm
passionate about introducing let's see
if the government are actually prepared
to put the right welfare that reforms it
was this magic money tree where's the
Magic Money Tree well well I mean we're
in this situation because of the
disaster yeah
eight or seven weeks ago seven or eight
weeks ago but if you can get more people
into work if you can aim to have the
highest employment in the G7 that grows
your economy and households are better
off as well so it's good for the economy
we would do other things we would invest
in an industrial strategy would invest
in green energy and onshore energy and
solar in wind farms in order to create
jobs but bring down people's bills well
we've said we would borrow the money for
that project but in the long term you
pay it off because you're increasing
jobs in your economy you're growing your
economy and you're bringing people's
bills down yeah but we are where we are
and we are a basket case when it comes
to our economy at the moment it looks as
though the chancellor has no choice but
to put up taxes that's something you
would support well
we've called for a fair taxation system
but you say you talk about battery case
they've been in for 12 years and we're
in this situation because the 12 years
of lackluster growth and the disastrous
budget of uh eight weeks ago war in
Europe and the covid pandemic yeah but
we could we could have weathered this
time I mean the war in Europe didn't
take away the 20 pound uplift in
Universal Credit
acted on inflation you know the war in
Europe didn't cut the pension that was
the uh that you know the pension Triple
A lot that was that was the government
look we believe in a fair taxation
system you can do more by taxing the big
bumper profit of the gas and oil
producers who are making profits because
of the war in Europe not because of Any
entrepreneurial Zeal on their part it's
just simply the international situation
has meant their profits have gone up we
can go further on the windfall tax on
that front we should be going to aren't
we isn't that the impression that we're
being given well there's so many
different uh kites flying I mean who
knows really I mean so much in the
papers the other day it suggests
everyone's going to be paying more
income tax it suggests that pensioners
are going to be paying more tax on their
pension so let's actually see where we
get to but we could extend the windfall
tax should get rid of the non-dom rating
for for people because that would bring
in billions we could use that money to
fund ex expanded staff isn't it to see
what people say well I'm pleased that
they're looking at some of the proposals
that the labor party have been putting
forward but the point I'm making is
there are there was a fairer way to tax
in this country and from the process of
that tax you could fund the investment
in your public services what do you
think about uh president Trump 2024
um I'm not surprised is announced but
the uh elections in the US last week
were disappointing for the Trump
supporters so I'm not convinced that
Trump is the if the Republicans want to
take about the White House
I'm not convinced that Trump is the
candidate to do it who is uh
uh Santos I guess the Republicans would
he seems to be the coming man for the
Republicans uh but I obviously as a
labor politician my sympathies are with
the Democrats and I'd want to see the
Democrats uh uh re-elected even when
you're in power in 2024 it'll be about
the same time as we see potentially a
change of power in the United States of
trump or DeSantis which would you rather
do business with well you know a
government has to do business with
whoever is the U.S president no I know
but obviously when you're in government
you do business with whoever whoever the
whoever the president is don't you
that's just the bonds between the United
States the United Kingdom are very very
deep so you you work with whoever the
president is but I mean who knows a lot
can change in two years but given the
performance of the Trump backed
candidates last week I'm not so sure if
Trump is the the best asset for the
Republican Party these days well let's
see it's good to see you as always Mr
Ashford thanks very much indeed